what researchers have found is that
people will experience you know what's
called schadenfreude which is
pleasure at the suffering of others but
they feel shocked and freud the most
when they see someone experience a
misfortune
who's similar to themselves you tend to
feel more shot employed for people who
are the same gender as us
so some reason to speculate oh this is
because if someone is roughly on your
level
they are a sexual competitor or maybe a
competitor for friends
for allies and so it might feel good to
see them sort of slip up a little bit
is everyone signaling all of the time
well yes i everyone is signaling all the
time
but people don't necessarily know
they're signaling and they're not
necessarily consciously signaling all of
the time
but however we are sending information
about ourselves at all times which is
sort of the classic academic definition
of signaling
what how would you define it someone's
new to the topic what's signaling
well signaling is basically uh we're all
constantly leaking information about
ourselves
uh from the way we talk the way we dress
the kinds of work that we do
the activities that we choose to engage
in
signals are information that other
people sort of pick up
based on what they see and what what
kind of information they're inferring
from from our behaviors
and so forth but the interesting thing
about that is not
all of the signals in fact probably most
of the signals
are unconscious
right yeah i think that well this is
basically borne out by the academic
researchers that this is not something
that we are
you know sort of sitting down and you
know calculating and deliberating how am
i going to send information about myself
what kind of information do i want to
send
and even when we do do those things uh
we're often not even aware of the
information that we we are sending so
for example
if i want to buy like a fancy car i'm
not thinking to myself like oh this is
really going to impress my friends and
it's going to give me a hot partner
and it's going to make me look great to
my co-workers or something
often it's just like this car makes me
feel good
and so i want to buy this car but you
know
as a lot of evolutionary psychology
research indicates
we don't do things just because they
feel good that feeling good has to have
some kind of
social payoff some kind of evolutionary
benefit
uh if you reach back far enough why that
feel why that feeling good is actually
something
uh you know that we feel that is so
positive is there a golden rule
of signaling is it like just why you do
what you do
might not really be why you do it
uh the golden golden rule of signaling i
mean
well i mean the first would be sort of
related to your first question i think
which is that uh the golden rule is that
we're always signaling
and that there's no escaping the
signaling game i've noticed
sometimes when i talk about signaling
with people they think like well i don't
do that
like that's that's silly like you know
this just sounds like people trying to
impress each other or whatever i'm not
i'm not into that
but even by saying that you're
communicating something about yourself
so there's no sort of escaping that
signaling game if i tell you like i
don't care what people think about me
you have learned something about me i
have humidity signal now
oh you're one of those guys who don't
care okay you're that kind of guy
right so there's no escaping that um do
you do you have a sort of rule about uh
signaling
no not at all man just that increasingly
i realize
how how tiny the sliver
of my motivations are that i get to see
and that the vast majority of the stuff
that my body and my mind are doing is
just completely on autopilot and i'm
just
i'm like cargo i'm just a long i'm just
along for the ride
i'm not passenger i can't even order
nuts off the air hostess i definitely
can't drive the plane
i'm just like i'm the suitcases in the
back
you know i've heard someone i can't
remember uh this was a psychologist who
described it as
like you know when you're walking
through like a video game arcade and
there's like the racing games and the
car is driving and you'll see like a
little kid get into the seat and he
didn't put any coins in he's just
sitting there pretending to drive the
car
uh the analogy i heard was that like
that's our life we are
in that driver's seat playing with that
steering wheel thinking we're driving
the car
but we are not something else is going
on and we're just sort of along for the
ride like you're saying
what are some of the examples of how
people might signal or some of your
favorite examples that you've seen
recently where it would be quite
surprising
uh well one that i just read so this was
an old study from like the
late 1950s in the u.s on these these
like
old-school behavioral psychologists um
organizational psychologist but anyway
they found that these executives in this
office
um somehow it became a game to see like
you know who could have a fancy pen on
their desk so at first they found that
like oh
you know each one of these executives
has one pen on their desk this sort of
fancy expensive
fountain pen or something and then the
psychologist came back
a few days later and one of the one of
the individuals had put two pens on
their desk and then
you know by the next day all of them had
two pens and then they kept doing this
and eventually
every every executive had multiple fancy
fountain pens on their desk
and you know i would bet that if you sat
down with them and asked like why do you
keep collecting these pens they're not
going to say like i'm trying to keep up
with the other guys i want to show that
i can afford these pens too
um they just sort of feel this pressure
of like oh well if i only have one and
that guy has five
people are going to look at me and that
makes me feel uncomfortable
you know there are some other
interesting examples of this from uh
research in inmating and evolutionary
psychology
uh you know for example if you show um
women images of the same man next to
uh you know sort of a typical sedan like
a four-door
kind of a sedan like a monster or
something and ask how attractive he is
versus um the same man next to
a luxury arm would be like a lexus or
something and ask how attractive he is
uh
it's the same guy same clothes same
everything just the car next to them is
different
the guy next to the lexus is rated as
much more attractive
and men on some level are aware of this
and this is why
so many guys are obsessed with buying
fancy cars
upgrades uh taking pictures of them i
have friends who are into this you know
they take
you know instagram you know look at what
i did to my car look at like how shiny
my rims are or whatever
um so that is actually a key
uh motivator for signaling is to uh
impress
impress romantic partners as well as you
know other kinds of
people is that upgrading of the car is
that an asian thing
is that because you got lots of asian
friends
uh well i actually don't have that many
uh asian friends
i um not like too fast too furious down
in cambridge is it not
it's oh it's not like that here the guy
i'm thinking he's actually an american
he's a white guy in america
he's really into cars um but yeah i mean
yeah
i'm sure this is probably at least you
know in
developed countries advanced economies i
would be very surprised
uh if uh for example men cared less
about
their cars than women i bet it's always
the young guys who care much more about
how their cars look
and how fast they are and how you know
how they look
so what's the signal with that in
evolutionary
psychology speak is it resource
acquisition is it conspicuous
consumption
yeah well okay so conspicuous
consumption
that comes from from economics uh which
is
so i mean this is actually a really neat
example of like
whatever like parsimony across the
sciences so biology and economics
both sort of converge on the same idea
of
what are called honest signals or costly
signals
so what a guy is communicating when they
can afford that expensive
fancy car um you know they're basically
saying you know i have a i have a job
i'm resourceful
i am conscientious because i can take
care of this um
and you know often luxury cars do take
more sort of
maintenance and upkeep and care uh
compared to
you know sort of a more sort of
downgraded less less luxurious car
um so that's that's definitely one
component of the student's pictures
conception
showing your economic uh uh position
and the sort of analogous idea
in biology uh sort of costly signaling
idea or the handicap principle some
people call it
um the sort of what
uh key example of this would be the
peacock's tale
um i'm sure you know many of your many
of your listeners have heard about this
idea from evolutionary biology
only a healthy bird can produce such you
know uh incredible and beautiful
plumage um that tail does not help that
peacock survive
in fact it does very much the opposite
it actually puts them at danger
if that peacock displays this tail um it
alerts predators to its position
uh if it tries to fly away that tail is
going to weigh it down
but when that that peacock shows its
tail to the peahens to the women
or the female peacock is trying to
attract is showing that like
look i'm so healthy and so robust and
strong that i can afford to
lug this thing around uh and therefore
you should mate with me and you know
we'll have some
you know some some offspring with some
with some quality quality jeans too
there's another animal that does this
too um
i think it's a gazelle uh some some kind
of uh
animal similar to that in in africa and
they do what's called starting
uh and what what this is is um if they
sense that a predator is nearby
like a lion or something uh they'll
start jumping
they'll immediately start jumping into
the air these are mostly the male uh
gazelles they'll start jumping and then
the research they're called starting and
what they're doing the researchers
believe that what they're doing is
uh showing the predators that i
am very strong very muscular this is how
high i can jump into the air
if you try to chase me you're not going
to catch me so just relax go for one of
those other guys who are who when they
stop they're not they're not jumping as
high as me
right um and often they'll do this as
well when there are female
uh gazelles around and this is sort of
to impress them too to show that like
look how high i'm jumping there's a
predator right there i'm drawing their
attention and i don't care this is how
how impressive i
am and you know i'm sure we can think of
some similar
examples with with guys too sometimes i
think
young guys do this with like um like
playing very loud music out of their
cars
what do you think what do you think the
signal of that is like listen to my
shite music well
i i think what like it is especially
like
late at night when there's a lot of you
know drunk people around and so on
sometimes i think like are they just
drawing the attention of
either unsavory people who would want to
like tell them to shut up or start a
fight with them
or if they're trying to draw the
attention of the police i mean
it's not usually a good idea in those
kinds of situations
late at night a lot of drinking going on
um and who knows what else
to suddenly start blaring loud music out
of your car and i
and again i don't think it's just con i
don't think guys in that car like let me
show off how
tough i am or whatever i think it's just
like some budding evolutionary
psychologists
driving around with neons under their
car and a base box in the back
there we go yeah yeah i mean this is
that's totally speculative i've never
seen any research on that but sometimes
i think that a lot of the
a lot of this stuff i mean even when i
was a young guy doing dumb things
i don't think that is conscious in any
way a lot of it is extremely risky
but that riskiness is uh you know
it's attractive um i've seen research
along these lines on on skateboarders um
so researchers did uh visit a skating
park
and what they found was that you know
they'd sort of interview these
young male skateboarders and sort of
look at how risky the the tricks or the
moves they were doing were in the
skating park and what they found was
that when they sent a young male
research assistant to interview them
uh they measured you know how risky the
activities they were doing compared to
when they sent a young female research
assistant to interview them
and when it was a young woman these
young male skateboarders were
taking much more risks uh incurred more
injuries
uh and they were you know sort of you
know in a way you could think of this as
starting or something right like they
were trying to show off to
to the young female versus versus the
guy who maybe they don't care
that much about about impressing but
sometimes guys do care about impressing
other guys and we can talk about that
too
yeah the fascinating thing i think about
signaling
is running back from what the action is
and trying to infer what all of the
different
branches are so it's kind of like a
reverse tree
i guess it's like roots so it's like you
have one thing that happens and then you
try and pull back from there so
you've got the the guy that always wants
to get in a fight
on a night out like what's that guy
signaling that guy's signaling i have
so much excess fitness and i'm so robust
that i am able to have what is a really
dangerous
altercation with someone drunk with a
hard floor
with other people around maybe taking on
multiple men
and um we spoke about this last time
that you were on where
if anyone has ever watched two guys
about to fight outside of a nightclub
the first thing that they'll do every
single time is circle each other
and that's precisely what you see when
you watch
lions or tigers or um
at stags you know about this circle
circle each other and maybe they'll push
which is gauging
each other's strength and um so much
every time that you send me
journal articles or articles to read and
stuff like that
i feel less and less removed from the
animal kingdom
that's the most gracious way that i can
put it
interesting yeah yeah i mean i i get
that too um
i've i've even seen like along these
lines about guys circling each other
there's um
there's an author rory miller i think is
his name he wrote a book called
meditations on violence and he worked in
law enforcement for a long time
and he calls this the monkey dance uh
you know to go that you know are we are
we animals are we
well he calls us the monkey dance uh
which is when two guys
he has like it's like um whatever like
the sequence that that he sees that just
like you're describing where at first
those sort of
uh verbally threatening each other what
are you looking at man you got a problem
that kind of thing and then they'll
start to sort of
you do the chest bump and then they'll
do the shoving match and
then at a certain point it will escalate
into you know a sort of roundhouse punch
with the dominant hand
and then the other guy tackles and you
know inevitably this is usually how it
goes right
and one of the things that he points out
is that
this almost always happens with one
almost always young man
and two it's they they do it with each
other right so young men are not going
to
engage in the monkey dance with uh with
a female at a nightclub i guess i have
seen like world star videos or something
occasionally some weird stuff happens
but overwhelmingly it's it's two young
guys
they usually aren't trying to fight
women they're usually not trying to
fight people who are much much older
uh or much much younger they're not
trying to do the monkey dance with
little kids right they're usually
same age roughly the same size yeah i
mean
very few are going to try to do the
monkey dance with like one of the
massive balancers or something
um and i i find that to be particularly
interesting too that we
sort of at least in that instance you
know they want to find someone who's
roughly on the same position
who it's sort of a question whether they
could beat them
right and that is sort of well you'll
get that maximal signaling value
is that where the friction occurs the
fact that you are within reaching
distance of each other in terms of
whatever hierarchy you see it to be
yeah i think that probably plays some
role
there was a sociologist roger gould he
wrote this book
um collision of wills where he actually
i mean his whole book
is about that specific question about
like when is conflict most likely to
arise between
individuals and you know he
he reviews a just a bunch of research
cross-culturally
within like sociology anthropology and
so on where he finds that
uh like basically equality of status
actually increases the likelihood of
conflict or
the absence of methods to establish uh
social position uh so a simple example
he gives
is um sort of the norms around age
typically uh we try to defer to our
elders elders usually have higher
positions in society
and so we defer to them but then he says
um imagine a workplace scenario
where the boss is actually the sort of
hot shot this young upstart
and his subordinate or her you know
employee is
is an older guy an older person
in that case you can imagine more
conflict than if the boss was the older
person and the young person was the
support in it
uh you know there are other other
instances of this as well
um where essentially if people aren't
sure you know who's supposed to be
the top person here how is this
hierarchy going to be settled then
conflict is is more likely i've also
been reading
this book um by diego ambada codes of
the underworld about
uh criminals and he documents research
in prisons
and finds that um when prisoners don't
know each other
fights are way more likely to break out
than
when prisoners have been around each
other for a long time and he posits that
this is because they're actually trying
to gain
information from one another they're
trying to elicit those signals
um when you have a new guy in the prison
they immediately want to size him up
you know see what he's made out of if uh
if he gets into a conflict with another
prisoner
all the other prisoners will surround
and say fight fight fight like they want
to know what's this guy
made of but if they've all been around
each other for a long time
number one a fight is less likely to
break out because they already know what
the pecking order
is and number two if a fight does break
out they're actually more likely to
break it up than encourage it because
they already know
like they're not going to gain any
signaling information we don't need to
create a problem in our little prison
community so let's just
you know let's not let's not get into
this let's just break this up
i think i heard you on a podcast talking
about
schools or foster homes being something
similar to that when you get a group of
sort of young kids together that's they
want to size each other up and
see what they see what they're made of
but once that's established it doesn't
really matter so much
i also read in one of the articles you
sent me
that we are less hierarchical
than other primates is that right well
yeah
in a sensitive so there's there's a lot
of like debate about this in
anthropology
and um but basically
what it looks like is you know according
to like christopher bain and other
other anthropologists if you look at the
ways that hunter-gatherer
uh communities are structured uh there's
actually not a firm hierarchy
they do have sort of like you know what
they'll sometimes call like big men
or like sort of like elders or something
who sort of make the decisions and these
are in like
hunter-gatherer forger communities in in
south america or africa or papua new
guinea
um and they also believe that this was
probably the case in early
hunter-gatherer cultures as well
you know hundreds of thousands of years
ago tens of thousands of years ago um
they that hunter-gatherers don't like
strict hierarchies
and they actually um will
downplay their own skills so if there's
a hunter who's particularly talented
um if they sort of managed to to take
out a large animal
uh the others around them around
this talented hunter will sort of make
fun of how he threw his spear or how he
runs or his appearance
because they don't want him to uh to
basically get a big head
they don't want him to sort of feel
arrogant or cocky
and this hunter will will go along with
it and say like haha you guys are right
like yeah and they'll sort of play that
that um
that role of being very humble and and
sort of downplaying their own skills
uh and this maintains social harmony
within those communities
um they themselves may not necessarily
put it this way but
it sort of suppresses envy uh they don't
want anyone to be too high
too much higher than anyone else um yeah
interestingly like hunter-gatherers seem
to be more monogamous
they don't like if you know one one male
uh like basically takes up all the women
and
they try to evenly distribute that as
well in terms of like romantic
relationships
uh it wasn't until later historically
speaking
after the rise of agriculture when
people could stay in one place and
accumulate wealth and resources
that tyrants could emerge and standing
armies and so on and then you could have
kings with
harems of thousands of women or
something but if you're a nomadic
hunter-gatherer
you can't really accumulate resources
and you can't really sort of
um take out your male competitors
if they all gang up against you and you
can't have like multiple lives
yeah i suppose that's one of the reasons
for dunbar's number
being around about that that it doesn't
once you get to sufficiently large if
you try and splinter off
to form some sort of a person moat you
know like a
roving gang of hunter-gatherer mobs
around you singing your loud music at
night with your neons on
like if you try and do that if you try
and do that
you just splinter off into a new group
um and you it requires a critical mass
of people
to actually be able to get that one
person who was the
the best hunter but decided not to be
humble if he was a dick
and if he if he was quite showy with it
someone would just take him out
after night a member of his family would
take him out to the woods and kill him
and then you would move on with your
life
so yeah it requires that that number of
people i suppose and the structure as
well and the culture
and the excess resources and all of that
stuff so oddly
oddly us maturing as a civilization
is one of the ways that we've become
less civilized
almost huh yeah well
yeah i guess when you when you think
about like civilization in terms of like
oh agriculture
and establishing settled communities and
so on
uh yeah i mean we did sort of stray from
that
egalitarian culture of you know that
sort of gunbar number of
of that small group the dunbar number
for uh listeners is basically this idea
that
human beings have this upper cognitive
capacity for how many people they can
basically stay on personal terms with
stay familiar with
and this is because hunter gathers bands
usually comprised of about 150 people
and then modern research sort of
supports this idea
uh if you look at the number of on
average number of christmas cards people
send out
the number of people they regularly stay
in contact with on social media you know
you might have a thousand facebook
friends
but you really only sort of regularly
stay in contact with
maybe 100 to 300 of them and sort of
converges around 150.
um and yeah that's that's a very
interesting idea that i mean to go back
to your earlier point about
sort of taking out the the arrogant
problematic male um
there was a recent book uh by the
harvard anthropologist i think he's
anthropologist richard wrangham
the goodness paradox and that whole book
is about this idea of
basically capital punishment uh
domesticated humans
he calls it self-domestication um where
essentially
early humans uh once they sort of you
know created these hunter-gatherer bands
and there would be if there was like a
sort of person who was creating a lot of
problems who maybe didn't care that much
what others
thought about him who would hog up the
resources who would try to steal another
person's life or whatever
um the sort of lower you know or maybe
the more humble
uh males say would would basically
organize and plot
and take this guy out um
usually through the use of like um like
extended weapons that would put
themselves at risk with spears or
something like that they would take him
out
or or bows and arrows
and so this was basically over time
after many iterations of this uh who are
the humans that
survived that sort of filtration
mechanism people who
are socially anxious who care what
others think about them who are very
alert to disapproval
who don't want to ruffle ruffle people's
feathers
who want to get along with the group
because
that feeling was adaptive uh 50 000
years ago
if you if suddenly you know the 150
members of your community
gave you a look that made you think that
there was something wrong with you
that was an indicator that you may not
be there for much longer
because the implications are now so
grave of you
moving around the status hierarchy i
suppose um
i've got this tedx talk coming up and
the the nerves are pretty palpable even
though it's only three weeks away or
still three weeks away
um and i think it's quite common people
say that one of the most
uncomfortable scary things people have
to do is public speaking and that's
supposedly an archetype of
our time as hunter gatherers as well
right yeah yeah that's that's
interesting
yeah i i mean there's research on for
example
uh cortisol responses so cortisol is a
hormone associated with stress
um researchers have measured the level
of cortisol
in sort of like lab settings they'll
bring participants in and have them do
stressful tasks
so for example if you ask participants
to do like mental arithmetic
or solving some difficult crossword
puzzles and then they'll take a saliva
sample and measure the amount of
cortisol
they release um so they'll take that
measure
and then they'll have you know other
participants do other kinds of
stressful tasks like deliver a speech in
front of a large crowd
or uh or a recording like a video
recording of themselves that
they believe will be seen by some
important person these sort of socially
stressful tasks
and research have found that in the
those more socially stressful tasks
cortisol levels are three times higher
than in the non-social
stressful tasks so if you're sort of
doing something difficult but you know
no one's going to see no one's going to
care
you'll feel a little stressed but if you
know people are going to be judging you
that's much more it's much more risky
uh much more stressful um
yeah that's uh i've also i can't
remember the specifics of this research
but um
naomi eisenberger she's a neuroscientist
who has she basically posited something
that
if you experience disapproval from
your social circle um and then this
might be related to like learning a
speech where you're
afraid that they may disapprove of you
the reason why your
heartbeat increases and your blood
vessels constrict and so on is because
your body is preparing in cat
in anticipation of either a physical
attack or exile
um and so that is you know this this is
not this is just sort of a
speculation but i find that to be quite
interesting and shows like what what's
at stake
in those moments right so you're saying
if i do
too bad of a tedx talk i'm going to have
to leave newcastle
yes they will exile you [ __ ] i'm
going to be i'm going to be chase chased
out of there with a spear
man i've got um i have almost an endless
number of examples that reinforce that
point that you've just brought up there
uh first one i'd i've done two reality
tv shows
one of them the first stage involved a
live audience of 400 people
the second one and and went out to maybe
a couple of million
the second one was over three in a bit
weeks probably accumulated tens of
millions of viewers
across that time but was just done with
the people that were on the show
and no audience first show despite the
fact that it
quantifiably objectively reached far
fewer people's eyes
because they weren't there in front of
me because they were on the other side
of a camera and then the other side of a
tv screen
didn't matter another one um i think i
told you this before i was riding a
moped
in uh bali i came off the moped because
i was paying 50 pence a day for a moped
like a dick and
i came off when i pulled the brakes hit
the floor
the two guys that i was with came over
the first thing that i felt
ahead of um fear for my personal safety
worries about the fact i was leaving
half of my skin
on this balinese course road the fact
that there was still traffic moving back
and forth because it's barley in they're
psychopaths
the first thing that i felt was like
shame
and embarrassment ahead of physical
risk i felt social embarrassment
that was how high on my list of lists of
priorities it was yeah
yeah well i mean our social image is is
is critical um
they're you know along these lines uh
there's been some some interesting
research in the last five years or so
uh basically comparing social pain
with with physical pain and what
neurosciences have basically found is
that they
they are overlapping neural regions they
occupy sort of the same
real estate in our brain uh when you
experience social pain the same part of
your brain activates
the anterior singular cortex uh and
the so basically if you are experiencing
social exclusion
um or some kind of like damage to your
image or status uh it sort of feels
similar
to actual physical pain and what's more
interesting i find is that
when researchers have asked participants
to um
basically say like think back to a time
so first they ask for you know they
recruit participants who have
experienced
some major physical or socially painful
event and they ask them um you know how
much pain did you feel at that
time when you got into that car accident
or broke that bone
um and they asked them how much pain did
you feel when you went through that
breakup
or when you found out your friend
betrayed you or whatever socially
painful thing it was
uh there's actually no difference when
they ask them how painful it was
uh they say both of those things whether
it's betrayal or breaking a bone those
both feel the same but then when they
ask
those participants to reimagine it like
imagine that you're back there again
uh now how much pain do you feel uh they
actually
remember the socially painful event to
be more painful than the physically
painful one
and they've also found that um
oftentimes people
have difficulty in their recollect and
trying to recollect
um physical pain uh it's hard like if
you broke the bone and you're trying to
think back like what did that actually
feel like
it's actually quite difficult for for
many people but almost everyone can
remember
what that tough breakup feels like uh or
you know what it was like to
sort of be excluded from a group you
wanted to join or something um
that feeling sort of remains with us
over time
and endures more so than the physical
pain why do you think that is
yeah yeah it's an interesting question i
mean
one thing is perhaps because physical
pain is
so almost instinctually aversive um
that you don't need to remember it right
nothing to learn from it
exactly you already know that that's
whatever it is like jumping in front of
a car is a bad idea you already know
that
whereas i almost think that like maybe
because
the social parts of ourselves and our
brains and our psychology it's more sort
of evolutionarily recent
and so we still have to sort of learn
learn the hard way so to speak
that if you get embarrassed or say
something wrong make a social topic
you want that pain to live on so that
you remember oh don't do that bad
thing again don't do that say that dumb
word again or whatever it happens to be
but that's just speculation dude i think
that you're right
i wonder as well whether
being hurt you know seriously if you
broke a bone
probably up until ten thousand years ago
five thousand years ago you were dead
if you break your arm you break your leg
you're probably dead there's probably
nothing to
learn how would how would the person
that learns from breaking the bone
or not lungs from breaking the bone have
ever been competed in or out of the gene
pool because that person probably just
dies so i don't know whether it would
have had a chance to interact
interesting yeah i mean i would have i
don't know enough about like
what what those early like human uh
clans and tribes were like
probably if you were a young person you
might be able to survive some of those
kinds of injuries but it would be i mean
it's nothing like today i mean it would
be like
you know very risky yeah uh but that
makes a lot of sense actually
yeah yeah i mean is the goal of
signaling usually status then
is that why people are doing it they
want to somehow
move up in terms of status right well i
mean
so that's definitely one goal social
status itself is usually
uh at least more recently it's been sort
of uh
divided into two kinds of pathways uh so
sort of two paths to the top i've heard
it described as so there's
uh there's dominance so one path to
obtaining status is
is dominance so this is basically the
ability to impose
physical costs on someone so someone
like like joseph stalin
or something like that is he's high
status right but he's
he's high status because of his
dominance his ability to hurt you
um whereas the other pathway is uh is
prestige so this is the
another component of status and this is
um basically someone's someone sort of
respect and admiration like how much
respect admiration
other have others had for them so
someone like uh
like stephen hawking right like stephen
hawking is not dominant you're probably
not afraid stephen hawking is going to
impose any physical
costs on you but you respect his
intellect and his ability to
communicate science or whatever um and
so those are sort of two distinct
pathways another way i've heard this
described is that
uh dominance is you know that kind of
status is what people can do to you
whereas prestige status is what people
can do for you
um and so you would want to make us you
know make uh
relationships build relationships and
associations with those prestigious
individuals and almost want to avoid the
dominant ones
um i think it sort of depends on your
society and the incentive structure and
so on but at least
i think in the modern west people are
much more preoccupied with signaling
uh prestige uh you know they want to be
admired they want to be respected
uh and in fact there's a lot of
interesting research indicating that
you know when you ask people you know
what sort of what's associated with
well-being
and and how good people feel and living
a comfortable life and so on and people
will usually point to socioeconomic
status how much money you have
maybe uh you know the kind of job you
work and so on but
actually um social status or
socio-metric status which is
uh respect and admiration from your
peers that has a much stronger
relationship with well-being and
self-esteem than socioeconomic status
so you know basically you can have all
this money but you may not feel that
great if you're if you're not
alike to people around you don't like if
you don't have many friends the friends
you do have maybe you have doubts about
how much you know how much respect they
have for you
uh and so signaling a key component of
it is
to uh basically build relationships with
people
friendships associates um
and of course romantic partners um
i've seen people ask this question about
you know because a lot of people sort of
read you know sort of
pop psychology books about evolutionary
psychology and they'll say like
okay so we know that men want to do
these cool impressive things because
they want to impress women
but then why do women want to do these
things like why do women want to become
lawyers and drive nice cars and wear
fancy clothes and stuff too well the
thing is like
it's not it's not just about me it's
also about our associates and our
friends and our community right like
you want to obtain the best friends you
can
and sort of build the the highest
quality relationships you can with the
most interesting people
and it's not just men who want to do
that women want to do that too
it seems to me that dominance
rather than prestige dominance is quite
obvious it's probably
more uncouth and looked down on
generally by society you know if you're
imposing your will on someone else and
that's how you're raising yourself up
people are happy at seeing someone raise
themselves up through their own talents
they're far less happy at seeing someone
raise themselves up by dragging other
people down
it seems like uh culturally and
legislatively
dominance status seeking has been
restricted whereas prestige status
seeking has been enabled
that makes sense to me yeah i guess it
would depend on
you know again like sort of the
incentive structure and and
sort of culturally i would imagine
somewhere in like a prison for example
dominance goes uh much further than
prestige
um or or in like organized like the
mafia right like
but look at the situation that's the
example it's where the laws have been
removed right
so i see yeah i think no i think that
you're correct
what are some status seeking behaviors
that people might not
realize they're doing right well
so it depends on you know even prestige
itself
uh is is sort of difficult to pin down
you know what what makes someone
prestigious
uh well for one uh
education right like people tend to want
to show off how smart they are
uh and how clever they are or witty um
which basically indicates that this
person can probably be a problem solver
or someone who you know basically i can
rely on to
solve solve problems or or to have
interesting conversations or whatever it
happens to be
um so how do we sort of signal our
smarts
uh in the modern age well i think
clearly one of them is education right
higher education
getting good grades going to college
those kinds of things
jeffrey miller has written at length
about this
in one of his books i think it's it was
his second this book spent i think it
was
where he basically says that like you
know
people are spending at least this in the
u.s context people are spending vast
sums of money
to go to college right like i don't know
what it is now if you want to get a
degree from harvard
200 000 or something like that and
miller posits that a huge reason for why
people are doing this
uh isn't for the education because you
can just go on youtube
and watch like super high quality
lectures
from the best scholars in the world for
free um
you know you can listen to podcasts or
whatever like all the information is out
there and it's available
so why would people spend you know fifty
to two hundred thousand dollars to get
that piece of paper
uh and militia that basically serves as
a guarantee
of like a minimal level of competence um
you know there's no way for me to look
at you or
and basically learn how clever you are
if you've watched a bunch of youtube
videos
but if you can put on your cv and show
me that you earned a diploma from this
university
i know a little something about you and
you might be willing to
pay tens of thousands of dollars to
prove that to me
um and then this of course will open the
open more
economic opportunities for you to get a
job and then earn more money
and so earning money of course signals
resourcefulness and and a little bit of
confidence in some degree as well
so that's an interesting question
actually what are the
uh characteristics we want to show other
people
and i definitely think one of them is is
smarts
what is the difficult to fake
element of all of this
right yeah yeah so so uh biologists have
distinguished between what they call a
cheap talk or um you know sort of cheap
signals
which are things that anyone can do
right i think
in the past in the mid 20th century it
used to actually be a little bit more
difficult
to obtain a like a high school high
school diploma
uh fewer people could actually go in the
first place because oftentimes kids
would have to work or whatever
um and then once that became sort of the
norm that everyone graduates
from high school today that that um that
credential
doesn't have the same signaling power so
you know i try to impress you with my
high school diploma today you may not be
so surprised
and so now i have to do something extra
go above and beyond
and sort of uh obtain that more
honest thing with a costly signal of
going to college so both
uh somehow acquiring the money to go to
college and then completing the degree
signals uh you know all of the qualities
i had just mentioned
um and this i think this brings us to
something about signaling that's
important
to remember which is that um it's not
like signaling is not like it's not
deception it's not
faking i think people sometimes get
these ideas mixed up and they're
they think like oh he's just signaling
so that means he's not really doing the
thing
um but actually signaling is is
signaling wouldn't work if if um
if it was completely decepti all
deception right
right it has to have it has to
communicate some real information
otherwise it wouldn't survive as a
system
and for the most part um only people
who have the underlying quality can
afford to produce the signal just like
with the peacock right the peacock only
the healthy peacock can
grow those feathers so we call that a
signal
um but this is not to say that that tail
isn't real or something
i suppose that the equivalent using the
education analogy would be
someone can sound as smart or as dumb as
you want during a short transaction but
it's only the person that's gone through
five years of university that has the
piece of paper
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's this quote
from robin hansen which i loved and it
says that
if we are built to hide ugly motives and
substitute pretty ones
we should suspect that our actual
motives are uglier than we think
i think that that's like a hanson's
razor
that we can use so so the razor would be
what that whatever you think your motive
is it's probably worse than that
yes precisely precisely correct so i was
talking to
diana fleischmann uh recently and she
was talking about how
she has so little faith in herself this
is a woman who is
balls deep in all of the eve psych work
and she just never she
has zero faith in herself she just sees
herself as this
myriad of competing
very unactualized sort of totally
complex
and and mostly conflicting ideas
floating around in her head and she just
doesn't believe
anything that she's got going on she
said that she feels like an alien
who's been put into a human's body said
this on the on the episode
she feels like an alien who's been put
into a human's body and at some point in
the future
she's going to have to report back to
the aliens about what it was like
and i suppose what she's because she's
quite big into mindfulness as well and i
think what she's talking about there is
the fact that
when you are very
conscious of the texture of your own
mind and where the motivations
are coming from or could be coming from
for why you act the way that you act
you actually do end up living the
observer
life rather than the behavior
life because you're constantly meta
questioning very metacognizant about why
did i do that thing why does this feel
isn't it interesting that i feel anxious
oh i can feel it in my neck i've got the
mindfulness i've got the
justification from evolutionary
psychology about why anxiety feels that
way
i can see the socio cultural
reason of why it's occurred because of
this situation
and yeah it actually probably makes it
very difficult oddly to be present
all the mindfulness probably takes you
out of the present she's so fascinated
at what's going on up top
that's yeah that is super interesting
uh yeah that sounds like very much like
like an evolutionary psychologist
perspective uh and then how they sort of
live in their own heads in that way
uh yeah i mean i that that makes sense
to me though that like the more you
learn
about the inner workings of your own
mind and your psychology and how
you know all of these things interact
the more you might
uh start to maybe second guess yourself
second guess your motives
you know why did i use that tone of
voice with that person um
you know why do i feel this i mean i
think one example of this
uh is uh i've heard this from multiple
people too like
like in the fitness realm where like if
you're trying to get in really good
shape
uh at first it's actually pretty easy
like that first sort of
few weeks it's actually pretty easy to
sort of you know lose the weight and
build yourself up or whatever
but then at a certain point like people
sort of hit that plateau
uh and you know number one it sort of
becomes harder to maybe lose the weight
or make that that incremental strength
gain
and sort of you start to like lose
motivation too so the
both the motivation causes you to hit
the plateau but then the plateau also
causes you to lose motivation
and i think part of what's going on
there is basically
your body recognizes that something is
changing
right like homeostasis has been
disrupted you lost a bunch of
fat or whatever your fat cells are
shrinking something's going on in your
body
and then it just hits the alarm button
and it's like let's take his energy away
like let's take his motivation away
let's make him hungry
like let's sort of make him not care as
much like you know whatever
the like smells will will be uh sort of
more apparent and powerful when you walk
past that bakery
right like suddenly your body is working
against you so that you're not
making your next fitness goal and that
to me makes a lot of sense that like
something so physical it puts your body
you know your body doesn't know that
you're just trying to lose a few pounds
right like it thinks you're starving
and so it's like what are you doing like
suddenly it transforms your psychology
uh and i think this might be sort of
yeah maybe like a similar example to
what maybe diana was talking about
we're just in a battle against ourselves
aren't we and this goes back to what i
said at the very beginning about as
being cargo
on the ship you just along for the ride
there was this cool thing
that you sent about this cycle of
conspicuous
leisure conspicuous consumption
conspicuous non-conformity and then
conspicuous authenticity
that we have now um it was basically
talking about what is the state of
seeking behavior that people are going
through
so early in the 1900s conspicuous
leather people
leather conspicuous leather people going
really expensive shoes
conspicuous leisure people going away on
holiday
conspicuous consumption people are
buying expensive cars conspicuous
non-conformity
counter-culture revolution 60s 70s it's
just peace man
and then the final one which is the most
painful one i think
conspicuous authenticity which is where
people are
open about their uh
their inner concerns about their fears
about their goals about their dreams and
think about what we're talking
so much in popular media at the moment
like jordan peterson
like it's all about personal growth
accepting your demons
facing the tyranny head-on you know what
i mean that is
conspicuous authenticity it's a
state-of-seeking behavior
it shows look i am this is how
trustworthy i am
this is how much you can have faith in
me i wouldn't i
i'm so virtuous that i can be completely
open and honest with you
and i'm still going to be okay
yeah yeah i mean there there is uh so so
there is a
sort of costly signaling component to
that right where like if you are
um revealing your vulnerabilities and
insecurities you know trying to be
maximally authentic
um i think you know and again
this isn't conscious but i think a part
of that is that you're sort of
communicating that like
i am in a position where i can sort of
show you my weaknesses
and i'll still be okay right like i'm so
sort of
you know in such a comfortable position
i'm so secure with myself
uh that i can do that whereas yeah i
could imagine that in
in other environments um revealing your
weaknesses is probably a very bad idea
so i could yeah maybe maybe if a society
reaches a level of comfort
then the way to sort of distinguish
yourself
in that comfortable reality is to sort
of reveal your
vulnerabilities which actually reminds
me uh if
we want to get into this is the the
counter signaling idea
there are signals and then there's
counter signals right which is uh
and more evidence i suppose that there's
no escaping the signal in game
so you know signals are basically what
we've been talking about this are
communicating information about yourself
counter signals are basically trying to
do the reverse
of what the signalers are trying to do
to distinguish yourself from them
uh and thereby raising your own status
in some way
so uh a simple example of this
i see i'm so there's a research for
example
on um i think this is phd dissertations
and what the researchers found was that
um
at lower ranking universities in the u.s
the linguistic complexity of the
dissertations
uh was higher sort of the the lower you
know whatever like the lower
lower uh ranked the schools the less
prestigious the schools
the more the students were trying to say
impress uh
the reader with how fancy the jargon is
or whatever
whereas at the higher ranking
universities the linguistic complexity
was actually lower
and the idea here is that you know i'm
i'm already
at this great university i don't need to
impress anyone with my language you
already know that i'm smart right like
that's sort of the idea so they're sort
of counter signaling i don't need to use
the jargon because
i'm already so great they've done this
too with
professors and they find that
professors at lower ranked universities
are much more likely to insist
on their title you know i'm the doctor
so and so i'm professor so and so
they put it on their syllabus they put
it on their voicemail on their door
whatever
and at the higher ranking universities
um they're less likely to insist on the
title
uh oftentimes they just say call me by
my first name uh
on their syllabus and their voicemail
and so on on their email signatures
they'll often just put their name uh
and the thinking here is sort of similar
if you're at a lower ranking university
you want to sort of
you know remind everyone like okay maybe
i'm at this lowering school but i'm
still
i'm still a professor right am i still a
doctor or whatever uh
and the higher ranking universities they
can counter signal against that but it's
not just in academia i think this works
in multiple different ways
how you dress for example i think uh you
know there's a reason why
people in tech will wear a hoodie to
work right that's counter signaling
the uh red sneaker effect is
the name for this it's the mental model
that was found
done at conventions for business leaders
and they managed to quantify how
formally people were dressed
and there was an inverse correlation
between the
uh how formal dress someone was in and
their net worth
and the red sneaker i learned that from
rory sutherland
uh that is interesting i suppose the
interesting thing
about status seeking behavior is that as
soon as it looks overtly status seeking
the whole house of cards tumbles
well yeah i i don't think anyone would
necessarily like
like think of it in that way but i think
that once the signal becomes too
ubiquitous
to where no longer communicates
distinctive information that's when
something has to change and people will
shift away from it so i would say that
like we don't respect behavior that's
done
mainly to gain status though right like
if someone
looks like they're just doing it to look
good they're just a flash
a flash prick yeah yeah that yeah okay i
get what you're saying and if
yeah we don't like that i mean it seems
like too smarmy
brown nosing or whatever where i'm
thinking about like job interviews for
example like often
the interviewer will say why do you want
this job and if the person just says
like i need money
or like you know i'm trying to get this
job to impress my friends or whatever it
happens to be if they use this very base
level like i'm just trying to increase
my
social or economic status in some way no
they
are asking you to impress me what can
you tell me that will
sort of show me that you're not a state
of stinky person
how can you show me that you care about
status without saying that you care
about status
uh which in itself is actually sort of a
test of confidence in a way
yeah how much can you kid me into
believing that
how what about envy how's envy related
to status
yeah well yeah so i think envy is one of
the
so i've once heard envy described as
like the only
so among the seven deadly sins envy is
the only one that people won't
brag about i don't know if this is true
but
i don't even know the other ones but
like gluttony or lust
like these are things that people will
maybe dress up to
but i don't know how many people are
willing to brag or
openly communicate the envy they feel
for others
um but yeah essentially envy is this
feeling that like someone else is
rising above you in some way and you
feel a little bit bad
about it and oftentimes will you know if
you have the chance
sabotage them um there's this research
uh i i know that uh william von hippel
he writes about this in his book um
basically what they did was they had
they brought in groups like pairs pairs
of people
into the lab and had to play a game um
so
in some instances it was two friends so
they bring two friends in so
at first one of the friends would be
playing this game and the other friend
would have the chance to sort of share
clues to help them win the game
uh what the researchers did was they
rigged the game so that the first person
who's playing the game
uh they rig it every time so that that
person always gets negative feedback
say like oh you really did poorly at
this sort of verbal puzzle task
and then they have them switch uh and
then
same thing the the friend is playing the
game the one who was just told they
didn't do very
well is now the one sharing clues and
what they found so
they did it with pairs of friends and
they did it with pairs of strangers
and what they found was that when it was
pairs of friends the friend who had been
the person i had been told they did
poorly was more helpful
to their friend than people were to
strangers but they were only more
helpful if they were told
that the task was trivial if they were
told that this is a task
of that that is an accurate measure of
verbal intelligence
then they were actually less helpful the
friend than they were to the stranger
they were actually
trying to kind of sabotage you could
think about their friend after they
realize like oh i'm
maybe i'm not very smart i don't want my
friend
to think that he she is much much
smarter than me so maybe i'll
be careful with what clues that i share
and they were more likely to do this
with their friend than with a stranger
which gets at this idea of you know we
tend to feel
envy more for people who we think of as
roughly on the same
level as us um it's pretty rare that
someone feels
a ton of envy for someone who's just so
far above them that like it's just not
realistic right like
you know an ordinary person isn't going
to look at i don't know george clooney
and feel some kind of envy when they see
him make another movie or something
but they might feel a little bit of envy
if they find out that their uh co-worker
just got a promotion
or someone in their field just did you
know someone some want some kind of
prestigious award or something
um and what the research has found is
that
people will experience you know what's
called shot and freud which is
pleasure at the suffering of others is
sort of the literal translation of it
but they feel shocked and freud the most
when they see
someone experience a misfortune
who's similar to themselves um
and so when you have people sort of
learn about someone read about someone
who's kind of similar to you
but doing just a little bit better and
then suddenly something bad happens to
them and people feel that little
burst of joy uh relative to someone
who's just not really in your social
circle not really
in your sort of your dunbar number or
something
they're so far outside of your sphere
something bad happens to them
you know you don't really feel as much
about what happens to them you don't
give as much pleasure at least
why do you think that's there well
some people have speculated this is sort
of due to sort of
mating competition um
i think there's a reason why we tend to
feel more shot employed for people who
are the same gender as us um
if something you know if a a woman
experiences misfortune guys are you know
they're less likely to feel happy about
that but if it's a guy who experienced
in this fortune they're like
good i'm glad now i now i'm a little bit
higher than him now
uh and so some reason to speculate oh
this is because
you know if if someone is roughly on
your level
they are a sexual competitor or maybe a
competitor for friends
for allies uh and
so it might feel good to see them sort
of slip up a little bit
um and yeah i mean
it's uh i guess this is one of those
sort of dark motives the hansen's razor
kind of thing of like
yeah it's tough it's tough to to
acknowledge and accept that this is a
a part of our nature but i think maybe
acknowledging it helps us to
you know maybe mitigate it a little bit
the enemy of my enemy is my friend that
to me seems to play out
so much more especially over the last
couple of years and
um i asked a question on my instagram
that i got a lot of a lot of answers to
but none of them were
that satisfying so i'm gonna pass the
question down to you
and it was around why people converge
on dislike groups a lot more
tightly knit than on things that they
like so for instance
if you were to go onto reddit and you
were to have a look at dave rubin's
subreddit it's been hijacked by people
who really hate dave rubin
it is so much more patriotic for hating
dave rubin than anyone that liked dave
rubin has ever been
if you go onto the fighter and the kid
it's
exactly the same brian callan and
brandon shop
it's just there's memes they've got
inner culture they've got inner workings
dude it is savage it's so bad and it's
a lot of people i'm gonna guess are
probably across the board or they've
just
both of the groups have arrived at the
same sort of talking cadence
uh separately why do you think it is
that
people find negativity so cohesive
as something to bind together around
again is it just a final
example there are certain youtube
channels out there
um philly on is one of them greg you set
is another more plates more dates derek
is another
they do these natty or not videos where
they call out people they
basically get suggested is this fitness
model on gear or not
almost almost always there's an
open-ended well he might be
or like he probably is or this seems
unrealistic
there is no equivalent on the positive
side of that
there is no isn't this guy in such great
condition
channel there isn't an equivalent of
that there isn't an equivalent of the
people that love dave rubin
is it to do with
people not wanting to just look like
simps on the internet
or is it something more is it something
more ingrained why do we bind together
around
mutual distaste so closely
yeah yeah that's a great question i mean
so
in related uh related idea from
political psychology research um what
researchers have recently found is that
uh
so at least until relatively recently if
you measure people's attitudes towards
just in the us context democrats and
republicans
how much they like their own party
versus dislike the other party people
tended to have more love
for their party than hate for the out
party right like
up until roughly 2012
that was the case and then starting in
2012 their hate for the out party was
much higher than their love for their
own party
so if you're a democrat it's not so much
that you like democrats just you really
hate republicans
and vice versa right and this has been
growing so 2016
it grew more and then 2020 just
continues so suddenly
we're uniting more around our dislike of
the out party than our own
in party in terms of politics which i
think is sort of getting at what you're
saying here but
because of why it's just yeah who really
it's it's a tough i think one thing that
comes to mind is um
well roy baumeister just has a book it
came out i think last year the year
before
uh something like the power of bad or
something
uh which is basically like if you look
at a lot of psychology research
uh there's a there's like a negativity
bias
that the bad stands out stronger than
the good um you're more likely to
remember
bad things uh sort of lock your
attention onto negative information it's
likely to stay with you
there's even research on social media
for what kinds of posts get shared and
retweeted
and overwhelmingly so like the top 15
words
that um basically if each one of these
words that you put in your tweet
increases the likelihood of getting
retweeted by 20
and overwhelmingly there are words like
attack blame
bad kill destroy hate
um and there's like out of 15 words
there's like three nice ones
it's like you know care or something but
even care can be used in a negative
conflict like who cares right
um and so i think this gets out
something about maybe our psychology
that like if
something is bad it just like activates
our
emotions more and
there is something about like wanting to
tear someone down that just feels
satisfying when you're doing it with
others
yeah so that's part of it the next step
is why does that bind people together
why do they find a commonality around
this mutual is it as simple as
in-group out-group tribalism
i think that well so if that that thing
that they're uniting around is clearly
an enemy
uh you know it can be perceived as a
threat
then you know we can all sort of agree
that like okay maybe we have some
quibbles about the principles of our own
community but we can all definitely
agree that what that person is doing is
wrong
there's no arguing it just feels good
like a disagreement can be uncomfortable
uh but you know agreement is nice and if
we can all sort of collectively agree
that that's something bad then
i think there is a sort of there's a
bonding experience there
um there's even you know some
researchers i think pascal boyer
he has suggested so he had his book
mines make societies and he suggested
that um
it's actually advantageous to exaggerate
uh so if you perceive someone as a
threat it's in your best interest to
exaggerate their misdeeds
um number one because you know if you
want allies
you want to convince them you want them
to be on the same page emotionally as
you
and so if they said something and used a
word or whatever and you think it's bad
um you know if other people don't think
it's bad you have to really sort of
convince them that like well if they say
this this is putting
our lives at risk it's putting our
safety at risk or our community or these
communities that we care about
and so it's in their best interest to
magnify every single potential
interpretation into something is
horrible
um one because it wins you allies
and then number two is if you want to
know
who's truly your ally who's really on
your team
um broadcasting goes those myst and then
seeing how people react to it will let
you know who's on my team and who's not
on my team
um and so if i say this person said bad
thing
and it puts us all at risk and out of
ten people seven of them are on my side
but three
of them are well i'm not so sure that
was so bad now you know oh
those are the three people those can be
next that we can all unite around right
like those are the next people
to be on the on the chopping board i
wonder if
part of it is game theoretical i wonder
if
some of it is to do with the fact that
if you're seeking agreement with
people about a thing there are multiple
different ways
that they might not arrive at how you
think that thing is good
whereas if you're seeking disagreement
oh sorry if you're seeking agreement
about thing being bad versus if you're
seeking agreement about a thing being
good
the agreement about someone that you
don't like might be
easier to arrive at because it's far
more simple to just
i hate that person than we like this but
oh yeah but do you also like this about
it do you also like this about it
i i wonder whether the negativity bias
shows up in the fact that it's
just simpler and it's easier to signal
that you are part of the same team by
doing it in that sort of a way
yeah that makes sense to me i mean you
also maybe don't have to provide as many
justifications
uh if you hate something and you can say
you know xyz like
it's just i think it's easier to justify
why you hate something versus if you
like something
then you have to put an argument for why
it's good yeah it might be harder
um liking things yeah maybe it just
doesn't have the same
emotional punch i've seen research so
this was out of i think stanford where
they basically uh looked at how people
choose to or how people do bond over
shared
likings of things how much they like
something and what the thing happens to
be and what they find is that
basically if two people learn that one
another
likes a popular band and then you ask
them you know how your favorability
ratings of each other
you know it's it's okay whatever like
they like the same band as me
it's like the rolling stones if it's a
popular band but if it's an obscure band
that very few people have heard of then
their favorite ability ratings are much
higher right like oh my god you know
that band too like wow that's crazy yeah
and so i think like liking is just more
nuanced it's harder there are more
there's more complications with it
whereas hate right like
you know if yeah if you can collectively
agree that you hate someone like that's
just
you know that's just easy right and yeah
yeah it's just
it's tough i think it's uh i think it's
it's
a pretty dark a dark aspect of our
psychology that
you hear so yeah a reason i think so i i
spend far
more time than i care to admit thinking
about dave rubin
and brendan schaub's subreddits like
it's just
you will go go and have a look at the
man they're an absolute
dumpster fire of like really
if they weren't so funny it wouldn't be
as bad but there's like some really
quite innovative
humor on there and what i was trying to
work out
what i was trying to work out was what
the common thread
between dave and brendan is that people
had a problem with
part of it is uh visibility
it's the fact that these guys have
managed to get themselves to a
sufficiently high social status that
people are like actually yeah [ __ ] this
guy
but the common thread and the term that
kind of underlies it is grifter
so what they're concerned about is
someone being
unreliable i think i think that's the
the underlying term of it
that there are these montages of joe
rogan saying a thing
and then brendan shaw agreeing with him
have you seen these
i have not dude they go on for they go
on for like
minutes like tens of minutes of
joel say like you know he's the baddest
guy in the planet and
brendan will god the baddest you know
totally the baddest and it's just
endless medleys of this and i think
what people are potentially trying to
highlight there
is this person is untrustworthy
they're prepared to compromise what they
believe
uh in service of someone who is slightly
higher state to stand them
so brendan always kind of um
he's got that younger brother older
brother kind of relationship thing going
on with rogan rogan says something he
reflects it back to him
you have dave rubin as well who gets
accused of having pivoted from one
particular viewpoint to another
particular viewpoint when that political
movement seemed to be like more
on trend he then attaches himself to
jordan peterson he then
attaches himself to the idw like none of
these things
i don't have a particularly strong
opinion i've never met brandon shaw but
i've spoken to dave rubin for 55 minutes
um i don't know if that's the case but i
think that that's the signal
that people are trying to identify and
one of the things that i've realized
and this is a really interesting part of
having your conversations watched is
if i don't disagree with people
sufficiently frequently on this show
you get you get a slippery slope of
people just
even if that i could have a thousand
guests and i could agree with every
single thing that they said
by pure chance without compromising my
values or being a simp
but people on the internet are so
simp conscious they're so like grift
aware
that they just ready on tenterhooks to
go
this guy appears to not be
not be pushing back you didn't push back
enough well
what if i did what if i agreed like what
am i going to push back against what if
i agreed
but there is a very hyper aware
grift sense grift radar that people have
on the internet
yeah i mean i think maybe part of that
is
okay so so there's research on basically
how people tend to obtain a sort of
status in social groups
and one way that people do it
is through displaying competence and
another way people do it is through
ingratiation
sort of displaying warmth or
friendliness and that's actually the
strategy that people tend to use
when they're trying to get people to
like them in social groups
and in fact displaying too much
confidence gets people to like dislike
them
uh if they're trying to advertise their
their abilities but if they're sort of
getting along with people agreeing
nodding friendly
being you know sort of smiling a lot
this
is a strategy that people use to gain
status and it tends to work
um i've seen research on like mba
students for example
uh the the ones that obtain the most
status and like they're sort of group
projects or whatever the people who are
the most friendly who share the most
knowledge
who are basically doing nice things um
but i think that you know the media like
like social media
and the internet it does like weird
things
like to those like if you're just trying
to be nice and friendly to someone and
sort of learn what they have to
say what they have to think like you
know that is a perfectly natural way to
communicate with
someone but then when you have thousands
or hundreds of thousands of people
watching
i think like some percentage of them are
going to be like
you know oh he's he's you know
ingratiating himself too much he's not
sort of pushing back or like you're
saying you know i think they
are sensitive to people who are
who they believe to be like seeking
status yeah
dude do you know what they don't approve
of do you know i think it might be
that i've just i've just considered
there
the guys who criticize regularly on
youtube channels
coffeezilla for instance and guys like
philly on and greg ducett
and derek for more plates more dates
they very rarely get mocked
maybe what they're signaling is
i am so competent i am so high status
that i
never need to ingratiate myself with
anyone
and i can still rise up through the
dominance hierarchy
interesting yeah that that i think
there's something to that i mean it may
also depend on your audience i mean i
don't know
what their audience is or whatever but
like i think maybe it could depend on
who you're who you're drawing who you're
attracting
i think something else might you know
it's complicated of course but i think
one thing might also be
people may just be simply experiencing
envy
um i i noticed that you mentioned so
there's the brian guy right like that's
he's a target of these people's attacks
but not joe himself i mean i know joe
good
his share of hate on the internet rogan
but it's not
i guess it's not the same and one
this is this is you know just purely
speculative but i could imagine one
reason is because
people might like sort of think that
brian is more closer to their level
right like they could imagine he's the
easy target
yeah like i could imagine hanging out
with joe being his younger brother being
in that position but they couldn't
necessarily
imagine joe rogan himself reuben
yeah maybe i mean like i'm a big fan of
it you know ruby
i've watched some of his videos and
whatever but like you know like maybe
they just think
that he's sort of not uh
impressive enough to be sufficiently
beyond that yeah
that could be as well both of those guys
both brandon and dave
do kind of play second string
to uh a front man that is you know you
jordan peterson ben shapiro
or joe rogan brian callan uh yeah that's
[ __ ] that's interesting man
what do you think what about covid19
how's that affected
or changed the way that people get
status
yeah well yeah this has been interesting
i think it's been uh i've heard multiple
people describe
the lockdowns as being like a boon for
introverts right
like i mean so i just attended uh an
academic conference this past weekend
and you know i talked to some people in
my department about this they like
other graduate students and they were
like the introverts were like oh that
was
awesome because like you could just send
some little message through the web app
and the presentations were all feel like
zoom and if you wanted to like network
it was just through these little chat
rooms or whatever and then like maybe
set up a skype meeting or something
later but
uh the extroverts in my department were
like that was awful like i didn't get to
talk to anyone
like i didn't get to you know meet up
with people there was no like you know
impromptu coffee
or drinks after like usually this
conference is in person and you can sort
of schmooze a little bit
but you know online you're sort of you
know
more limited more constrained and i
think for introverts this is
uh this is creating some opportunities
um
yeah it's also harder in some ways i
think for
extroverts right like they can't get out
as much but
i don't know i've also seen some
conflicting research as well that
extroverts are actually handling
lockdowns better than introverts uh
some people speculate that extroverts
are are still being extroverted just on
the internet
um they're still using zoom and meetings
and facetime and whatever to stay in
contact with people whereas introverts
are
you know they're not forced to be social
anymore which of course they might
think that that's great and nice but
oftentimes you know they may not be
aware of how much they need that
social interactions to stay healthy
right
um i mean in fact there's actually
research on this on like authenticity
uh to go back to the earlier point about
authenticity that
people tend to feel more authentic
regardless of their actual personality
just
you know just uh dispositions they feel
more authentic
after they have behaved in a more
extroverted fashion
uh and so if you think about you know
you might
think that people feel more authentic
when they behave in line with you know
who they are
but actually they behave more you know
they feel authentic when they behave in
line with
who they want to be which is usually
someone who's friendly outgoing
extroverted that's sort of the cultural
ideal
they've narrowed the domain of how you
can
gain status has been narrowed though
right
like the example of the very commanding
boss who can just own the boardroom
because of the
the way that he walks in and the suit
that he wears and the car that he pulls
up in outside and the way he smells
and the watch he's got on and his body
language you know that's all been
reduced down to a
little screen that he takes up a
pixelated version of
so you know if i was a more ambitious
graduate student
one idea that i had uh was
to basically like uh try to figure out
how people
detect status queues in webcam
zoom skype environments right so like
i'm looking at you i look in your room
i sort of you know see all of these cues
you know you're admitting
you know you even you yourself you know
it's not you it's your belongings
there's also an emit signals as well
how people sort of encode those and what
they what they learn about people what
they you know how accurate those
perceptions are
uh how much they align with reality i
think that would be fascinating because
you know like you're saying in the past
it was you know the boss in the office
and you know maybe they're walking a
certain way and they have that
the car or whatever but they're to some
degree
there's this kind of level playing field
because you're all in the same building
doing the same stuff adhering to the
same dress code
but when you're working from home you
know a lot of companies have sort of
you know softened the dress code a
little bit
maybe working different hours or
whatever and you can sort of see what's
behind people
what what you know where they choose to
work what's behind them and so on
and i wonder if people are looking at
their co-workers differently now
you know even if it's not there's no
embarrassing moments with the catwalking
buyers
even if it's just you're in your room do
you view your coworker differently now
based on what you see behind them
um have they elevated themselves in your
mind or maybe lowered themselves a bit
um but yeah yeah i think that it's it's
definitely constrained and
created uh both opportunities and
and obstacles uh to gain status but
i don't know i don't know about email
but i've been posting more on social
media and like trying to like
i don't know make have more of these
kinds of conversations and so on and
i don't know it hasn't been a terrible
year for me no
not for me either i was saying the other
day over the last
year or 18 months or so i've developed
and you're
you're one of them buddies who i can
ring without organizing
like i don't book it in on the calendar
i just ring and see if they're free
and if they are i have a conversation
for like two hours and then put the
phone down
like we did this maybe about a month ago
or so just rang
ended up chewing each other's ears off
i'm reading to you from books you're
like off on a walking cooking or on the
phone for ages
so there's certain elements i think that
have really helped us to connect
have you heard about the zoom boom of
lockdown
face do you know about this i have no
idea what that is
so there has been a significant increase
in cosmetic surgeries from the neck and
above
and it's because people are looking at
themselves
on zoom all day and they're realizing
that they're
particularly unhappy with the way that
they look so
plastic surgeons are noting a zoom boom
that's yeah i mean that makes a lot of
sense honestly um
yeah yeah i mean people are pretty hard
on themselves uh
in terms of their appearance i've
actually seen some some interesting
research on this you know people sort of
assess their own appearance
and other people too like you know
people
i mean more so women tend to be harder
on their own appearance than than you
know more objective unbiased observers
um so that makes sense if you're sort of
looking at your own image and you're
sort of
hard on yourself that you would you
would feel that um
and yeah i mean this this brings to mind
some some interesting research about
like
self perceptions i mean oftentimes we
only look at each other you know
ourselves rather in the mirror in the
morning or something maybe in the
bathroom
walking past but now we're looking at
his you know our own face
all day long and
and the research sort of shows like how
do people view themselves
and so they basically take in people's
pictures
uh and either sort of show them the real
picture or a picture they sort of
modified to be
i think 20 more attractive and i can't
remember exactly how they did this but
basically a more attractive version of
the same face
and if you ask people you know we took a
photo of you one of these is the actual
photo which one is it people
overwhelmingly choose the 20
more attractive face um and now i guess
we can't really pull ourselves in that
way because you're looking at the real
face not the 20
more sort of psychological image we
carry around with ourselves all day um
yeah i mean i think that that research
is yeah i mean
in in von hippel's book he actually
talks about this about how
you know we don't like candid
photos of ourselves uh not because our
friends are bad photographers but
because
that's what we actually look like uh we
tend to look at
the images of ourselves we see the most
are like that professional portrait
photo the one with the lighting just
right and the filters and this and that
and we see that and that's how we think
of ourselves
uh but actually the candid photo is who
you really are
and now we're seeing that candid photo
yeah that's yeah i didn't think about
that man
the photo from the side where the
hairline's wonky and you can see that
you actually missed a little bit when
you were shaving earlier on today
yeah man it's uh what if confidence
levels have declined
since uh since all this yeah
i don't know one of the most
fun uh mental model effect that i
learned last year
was how you can get laid more easily
by going out with a guy who looks
similar but slightly more
ugly than you so you're basically
utilizing the anchoring bias
but the problem is if meaning you go if
me and you go out together no one's
confusing me for you
different ethnicity different sort of
look what you need to find
is a slightly more ugly shorter fatter
asian
or i need to go out and find a guy who
looks a little bit like me
but like you know a bit more of a wonky
nose and you know a bit of a slump maybe
maybe he's a bit slumpy and uh that
because what people see is they anchor
you
against someone that looks similar to
you but when you're anchoring too
completely
i can't compare an iphone to the price
of a jet but i can compare an iphone to
the price of a samsung
and um right yeah that that anchoring
effect was was something that i read
about last year which was
hilarious yeah yeah
i mean i when i hear that i think about
like um
sort of positional status like you know
in economics it's called positional
goods you know
social status is is uh it's not absolute
right it's relative
it's not you know you're not ranked on
some objective scale with the entire
world you're mostly arranged with the
people
who are just around you um you know i
know economists have done
research you know simple versions of
this where like they ask people would
you rather make
uh sixty thousand dollars a year but
everyone at your firm of the same rank
makes 50 versus you know making 80 but
everyone else around you makes 90 people
choose the first option they're making
absolutely less but you know they're
higher than everyone
around them uh i once uh you know just
along this sort of uh relative status
line i heard this uh
this is a i think this is a jewish
folklore story there's a man who's
walking along the beach and he sees a
lamp
he rubs it and then there's a genie and
he says to him
i will grant you whatever wish you want
but
i will give your neighbor twice as much
as whatever i give you
and the man stops and he thinks and he
asks the genie
i want you to pluck one of my eyes out
and
so the idea here is that people will
actually incur
damage to themselves it costs if it will
bring the closest person to them
sort of on that same level you know
lower than themselves
um i heard there was an irish variation
of this where the guy asks the genie
he says i want you to beat me half to
death um
and i think this sort of captures that
that intuition of like
you know it's not it's not um something
that
you know we're not ranked on this this
scale that we can
very very neatly say that like oh more
of this is always good sometimes more of
something isn't always good if everyone
around
you is getting even more of that thing
right if i offer you
you know 10 iq points that might sound
great but if i'm going to give everyone
else 20
now you're actually absolutely smart of
a relatively little dumber and that's
that's hard right man we were gonna do
we were gonna do another one but we're
just gonna have to do it in future this
has been far too fun
uh people want to check out your awesome
newsletter or your fantastic twitter
where should they go uh yeah
the website is just rob k henderson.com
letter k
uh and then twitter saying rob k
henderson
the most underrated follow on twitter
in 2021 i said it to the other day man i
really really appreciate you coming on
we've got so much to go through we've
got all stuff to do with cultural
evolution and
coalitional instinct we're gonna do
another episode soon but we'll leave
this one here
thank you so much for coming on man yeah
thank you
[Music]